So we all know that we encounter stressful situations throughout the day, week,
and even our lifetime. In fact, throughout one day we may experience different
levels of stress. For example, perhaps you oversleep and you're going to be
late for work. Or you're stuck in traffic and you're going to be late for an
exam. Even worrying about a sick pet can cause stress. You might find it
interesting to know however that not all stressful events are threatening or
bad or frightening. In fact some events that are supposed to be pleasurable or
fun can also produce stress. To that end in the 1960s two psychologists
invented a scale called the social readjustment rating scale. And we're going
to go back to Lauren to look a little bit more closely at that scale.